a threesome might be really enjoyable
are you expressing interest gam i've
always had an interest
adrian banfield norris is putting it all
out on the table
leaving her granddaughter willow smith
totally shocked
it takes practice to have those
difficult conversations
on the latest episode of red table talk
on facebook watch
willow joins her grandma adrian and her
mom jada pinkett smith
to discuss romantic relationships
between women which eventually leads to
adrien aka
gammy's unexpected confession with it
and i know i've thought about oh well a
threesome might be
really enjoyable but just could never
you know
how i was raised with all that guilt and
shame around so i definitely didn't have
the freedom to consider it
as far as love is concerned yeah are you
expressing
interest gam i've always had an interest
adrian also goes on to explain
why exactly she thinks a threesome would
be interesting
it just seems like sexually it would be
extremely
pleasurable exactly
let's put it on the table and although
adrian says she's even talked to her
husband about it
she admits she's still hesitant to try
it i think it's too late in my life to
to be that
experimental at this age i don't think
this is how i feel i'm not
well if i wasn't willing to do it then
i'm not i'm still not willing to do it
now
i think it's important in all honesty
for a daughter
to for your kids yeah to
have the opportunity to um
see their parents and listen to their
parents talk about
different stages of life that you go
through
another surprising moment from the
episode willow smith envisioning jada's
next relationship
you just said something so interesting
to me the other day and you're like mom
you think if anything ever happened with
you and dad i think you could be with a
woman
i was like what i mean this is the thing
that feeling that you get when you're
with your sisters that understanding
and that acceptance and that that
softness i feel like
is very appealing
the episode also featured guest niecy
nash who joined the family at the red
table
to dish on her recent marriage to wife
jessica betts
i've never dated a woman in my life
until now
but it was the first time in my life i
had ever felt fully
seen and it changed me
she also goes on to say that it was hard
for some people around her to understand
what i say to that is i am everything
you thought i was i just laid my head
somewhere else
yeah and earlier this month nisi told et
that this is the happiest she's ever
been it has something to
do with how your love
i think it's different you know because
sometimes you could spend a lot of time
having to interpret your love language
now
preach somebody somebody talking right
you